The joe rogan experience,
if you always like that.
I was reading something really interesting
where they were saying that they are
are fucking up the brand because they've
put them into discount stores that
they're trying to raise the sails and
by raising the sales they put them in a
discount stores.
By putting them in the discount stores,
they're going to change the
way people look at the brand.
It's not going to be worth as much.
That's probably very realistic, man.
That's very interesting.
Weird people think so weird and know
like if you saw a pair of Nike's at a
discount store, would you like
Google folk? Nokia were like,
and what that what that means zero to me.
Yeah. No, and they hit mean in Nike has
a outlet stores, which is like discount.
Yes. You know, so that's, that's kind
of weird, but it is true about how,
I mean the other one is like that big
baller brand there basically attempting to
compete in the apparel
world. Lavar Ball, right? Yeah.
That's the guy that got in that crazy
thing because his son was arrested in
China for shoplifting the China. He
was in China. Yeah, he was shoplifting.
And then Trump says he got 'em out and
the dad says he didn't get them out.
Yeah, it's that, that's him then.
And then the dad is, you know,
Trump's calling the data.
What happened? That trumps, I mean
well that guy is very brash Lavar ball.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I mean I think you know that guy
knows what he's doing man. As far as,
as far as PR,
definitely.
He knows he's going to say some wild
shit and he knows people are going to be
like, oh my God, what did he say?
And then he knows that that
gets him more press and like it,
it kind of just feeds itself and people
act like he believed the fucking crazy
shit that asshole just said. And
he's like, yeah, that's what I do.
And that's why you keep putting me on
the show like Trump when he was running
for prom 100% it's the same school
of thought. And now though that guy,
so he has a son named Lonzo plays
for the Lakers. Who's a first round,
first round draft pick, like
a, a top tier player from Ucla.
Then his other son was two more sons.
One of them was on Ucla team this year,
got arrested for shoplifting in China.
If he hadn't been released,
if it wasn't high politically,
you know, highly publicized thing.
He definitely could have gone
to jail for a while in China.
They don't fuck around,
you know, so, but anyways,
when he got out and came back Lavar
pulled him from like from school,
from Ucla and also pulled his 16 year
old son at a high school and flew them to
Lithuania where they're now playing.
Both of them were playing professional
basketball in Lithuania and professional
professional class quotes.
Jamie did the air quotes.
It's got to be in big air quotes for sure.
Well, I mean there's definitely some,
some good players that come out
of there, but it's like, um,
I mean it is a circus over there. If you
see like how it was when they arrived,
it was like, it's like some, it's
crazy. The reception, you know,
what is he trying to do now?
He's trying to start some new league.
He's trying to do a couple things.
He started a brand big baller brand and
they know that's like ball and beaten
and came out with these shoes.
They're basically $500 retail sneakers.
And if you're like, that's
expensive. He's like,
cause you're not a big baller bitch.
That's why not.
That's like what are they like made by
a real organization? Well Adidas, no,
no, no, no, no. They're not made by
definitely not any. And by the way,
the sun that's in the MBA
turned down real money,
like real fucking money
because he was like, I the,
the father demanded that you basically
pay to develop this brand from the big
uh, apparel. And the guy's like,
give us like a billion dollar contract
and like develop this brand. What?
And they were like, no, we're
not doing that. And he's like,
well then we're not even gonna talk to
you about endorsing my science. Seriously.
100% yes.
Then now he's had like,
there's so much a conversation about
the brand that he's definitely elevated.
Like the awareness of it. What? We
don't know what nobody knows is like,
to what level are they actually selling
this apparel? You know, like are they,
because they have everything, they
have shirts and shoes they're getting,
they just got it rated an
f by the better business.
Right around their shoes are not the ones
they sold the previous sold a bunch of
shoes and there's like the
ones that people are getting
are not what they bought.
So people are pissed. There's no
way to return or the fun. Yeah.
Great fun to or exchange them.
Yeah.
And they're just telling
people they're literally,
I think I read that the customer
service people told you, you, oh,
you must be a brook baller then.
Yeah. You're not satisfied. Yeah.
That's literally what it, oh my God.
But he's also, I mean he's, so anyways,
he stays, he's about, he
took these kids to Lithuania,
they're going to play basketball.
He's like,
he basically says they're going to be on
the Lakers when my three sons are going
to be Lakers. Right. So,
and we have no idea really realistically
whether the two younger sons even have,
we don't know. To be fair, whether they're
going to be MBA quality players yet,
you know, like the clearly one
is the one is on the Lakers,
but so we don't know if that's going
to pan out in any way, shape or form.
He also talked about developing a league
for like kids that are coming out of
high school that don't want
to go to college and play
in a league where they get
paid like a salary, you
know, a reasonable salary,
which is, uh, an an idea that a
lot of people think is fascinating.
I don't know logistically whether
he could pull that off. You know,
that's kind of a, I got to know
for sure. Right? I mean, but,
but the idea is one that people have
talked about for years because college
athletes generate a lot of revenue
[inaudible].